[Aplausos]
[Música]
uruguay es un país famoso por su
selección de fútbol de hecho ahora que
se celebra el mundial de fútbol en rusia
hemos repasado el palmarés y resulta que
solamente hay 8 países que han ganado la
copa del mundo alguna vez pues bien
uruguay con sólo 3 millones de
habitantes la ha ganado dos veces
y además en ambos casos fueron victorias
contra dos países con los que comparte
fronteras brasil y argentina- y
precisamente de eso vamos a hablar en el
vídeo de hoy de como uruguay ha
conseguido superar a sus vecinos aunque
no no vamos a hablar de fútbol vamos a
hablar de economía porque mis queridos
amigos de visual política
uruguay es uno de los países más ricos
de toda latinoamérica al menos en renta
per cápita también es uno de los más
estables y con mejores servicios
públicos y en lo que a política se
refiere
uruguay tampoco se queda atrás os
acordáis de su ex presidente josé mujica
se trata de la gran rockstar de la
izquierda no sólo latinoamericana sino
mundial más conocido como el presidente
más pobre del mundo
desde el punto de vista de la filosofía
de la vida es mejor vivir liviano de
equipaje con lo justo pocas
complicaciones desde el punto de vista
material porque si tienes muchas
complicaciones gastas mucho tiempo josé
mujica ex presidente de uruguay sin
embargo mientras mujica vivía con tan
poco dinero su país crecía atrae a
empresas extranjeras y se convertía en
un pionero en avances sociales con
mujica en el poder
uruguay aprobó el matrimonio homosexual
pero sin duda alguna su medida más
conocida fue la legalización de la venta
de marihuana mucho antes que california
o cualquier otro país uruguay fue el
primer país del mundo en permitir el
comercio de cannabis para uso recreativo
[Música]
pero no sólo eso veréis si hacemos una
foto fija de uruguay podríamos decir que
es el mejor país para vivir de todo
latinoamérica a diferencia de brasil y
argentina que son sus vecinos uruguay no
ha dejado de crecer económicamente desde
el año 2002 tiene una clase media
pujante y los sueldos más altos de todo
latinoamérica compitiendo mano a mano
con chile pero esperad un momento porque
no todo es tan bonito en realidad para
ser un país tan próspero llama la
atención que apenas sea capaz de atraer
a inmigrantes y no es porque tengan unas
leyes de inmigración especialmente duras
lo cierto es que muy poquita gente elige
vivir en este país y la razón es que en
los últimos años las cosas se están
empezando a torcer así que la pregunta
es por qué la economía de uruguay ha
funcionado hasta ahora qué méritos le
tenemos que reconocer a josé mujica y
cuáles son esos nubarrones que acabamos
de mencionar hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
la suiza de américa uruguay nació en el
año 1830 tras una guerra entre brasil y
argentina- a los británicos que fueron
los que negociaron la paz les interesaba
que uruguay fuera independiente el
puerto de montevideo era una auténtica
joya y no querían que cayera en manos de
ninguno de esos dos grandes países y
quienes vivían en uruguay pues
prácticamente nadie había una tribu los
llamados charrúas pero eran muy pocos y
en seguida fueron exterminados y por eso
a diferencia de otros países
latinoamericanos casi todos los
uruguayos son de origen europeo
más concretamente español e italiano
[Música]
por aquellos años si eras un chico con
ambiciones uruguay era el lugar donde
estar a la misma altura que eeuu o
argentina
hablábamos de una democracia moderna y
con estado de derecho los datos no
engañan en un país con buenas
condiciones de vida y ajenos a grandes
conflictos la población pasó de un
millón en 1900 a dos millones a mediados
de siglo y tres millones y medio en la
actualidad
[Música]
un crecimiento de la población lento
pero estable y al igual que sus vecinas
de argentina uruguay era un país muy
rico de hecho hasta los años 60 estaba
muy por encima de españa y de muchos
otros países europeos así que ahora os
preguntaréis en qué momento cambió todo
para uruguay porque una cosa está clara
aunque sean una de las economías más
prósperas de latinoamérica están lejos
del nivel de vida de casi cualquier país
europeo así que qué ocurrió
[Música]
pues la respuesta está en la comunidad
económica europea lo que luego sería la
unión europea tal cual como lo oís y es
que mis queridos amigos de visual
política si pensaba es que esto de las
guerras comerciales es un invento de
donald trump estáis muy pero que muy
equivocados con la creación en el año
1958 del mercado común europa se cerró
en banda para las carnes uruguayas así
que el único amigo rico que le quedaba
este país era eeuu pero en plena guerra
fría el tío sam tampoco tenía mucho
interés en hacer acuerdos comerciales
con uruguay bastante tenían con lidiar
con otros países más problemáticos
[Música]
así que de la noche a la mañana la
economía de uruguay se estancó y en
montevideo no les quedó otro remedio que
mirar más a sus vecinos especialmente a
argentina que se convirtió en el
principal destino de las exportaciones
de este país
de repente uruguay se convirtió en algo
así como el robert rodríguez y quentin
tarantino de latinoamérica que argentina
tenía una crisis pues uruguay también
que argentina tenía una dictadura
militar pues uruguay también que
argentina tenía una democracia
lo habéis entendido y mis queridos
amigos de visual político que ocurrió en
argentina en el año 2002
exacto el famoso corralito una de las
mayores catástrofes financieras de la
historia para que os hagáis una idea en
2002 el pib uruguayo cae un 77 % una
auténtica calamidad de proporciones
nacho vidal ianas y ese fue el momento
en el que uruguay se dio cuenta de que
tenía que cambiar de socios comerciales
pero cómo se puede hacer eso
pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
el 'kilómetro cero' de américa latina en
los años 80 los primeros gobiernos
democráticos de uruguay hicieron una
cosa muy interesante sentar las bases
legales para el desarrollo de zonas
francas y os preguntaréis qué son estas
zonas francas pues son nada más y nada
menos que territorios donde el gobierno
ha decretado que no se pagan impuestos
nacionales ni el iva ni el impuesto de
la renta ni el impuesto de sociedades-
la única exigencia es que el 75 por
ciento del empleo tiene que ir destinado
a la población local
[Música]
o suena de algo sí exacto es como las
zonas económicas especiales que tanto
les gustan los chinos pero esta vez
creadas al cien por cien por uruguayos
uruguay tiene 11 zonas francas y las hay
de tres tipos en primer lugar las
orientadas a la logística y el comercio
exterior en segundo lugar las que sirven
de base a multinacionales para prestar
su servicio en toda latinoamérica y
finalmente las zonas especialmente
preparadas para la industria
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque aquí no
termina la cosa estas zonas francas
tienen una ventaja única algo que hace
de uruguay un país modélico y estamos
hablando de la estabilidad política
creéis que es una tontería pues nada de
eso en el año 2005 uruguay tuvo un
cambio de gobierno pasaron de tener un
presidente de centroderecha a uno de
centroizquierda en este caso hablamos de
tabaré vázquez del partido frente amplio
en otros países esto podría significar
el fin de estas zonas francas verdad o
es nada de eso si algo caracteriza a
uruguay es el consenso entre partidos
[Música]
se explica que entre el año 2005 y 2014
la inversión acumulada en las zonas
francas llegó a casi 6 mil millones de
dólares y todo esto mientras tabaré
vázquez primero hijos en música después
gobernaban el país porque en el mundo no
sólo se busca ganancias se busca también
seguridad
y eso lo ofrece el uruguay no es un
problema de este gobierno ni del otro
y es una actitud de los uruguayos y
ahora os preguntaréis cuál es el
beneficio que saco uruguay de las zonas
francas cuando no pagan impuestos pues
mis queridos amigos de visual política
el beneficio es doble por un lado se
establecen en uruguay industrias que en
igualdad de condiciones buscarían otros
mercados con mayor número de
consumidores y estas grandes empresas
necesitan proveedores así que enseguida
surgen pequeñas empresas locales a su
alrededor y por supuesto los empleos que
se generan son cualificados y con buenos
sueldos es decir que los uruguayos no
tienen que emigrar para encontrar un
trabajo
[Música]
pero hoy todo esto que tiene que ver con
cambiar de socios comerciales es mucho
porque gracias a estas zonas francas
uruguay pudo dejar de producir
únicamente carne y soja para empezar a
vender productos de valor añadido por
ejemplo ahora mismo uruguay hace los
concentrados de pepsi para toda
latinoamérica es más hay una bebida que
triunfa en japón que se llama la pepsi
azul y se hace a partir de un vegetal
que es el haba dulce pues bien el jarabe
para hacer esta bebida se fabrica a 200
kilómetros de montevideo
para que os hagáis una idea la pepsi
supone el 7 por ciento de las
exportaciones de uruguay pero hay más
casos una de las principales papeleras
del mundo la empresa finlandesa upm
tiene una de sus principales plantas de
producción en uruguay y según han dicho
van a construir otra planta más que
podría suponer un 2,5 por ciento más de
pib para el país pero esperad un momento
porque todavía hay más en uruguay
también tenemos otros sectores como el
del software
[Música]
8 desarrolladoras de apps uruguayas
entre las mejores de américa latina'
en definitiva más del 30 por ciento de
las exportaciones de uruguay se hacen ya
desde estas zonas francas ya que no
adivináis quién es el principal
comprador de los productos uruguayos una
pista empieza por sí y acaba por nada
para que os hagáis una idea brasil y
argentina han pasado ya a ser solamente
un 20 por ciento de las exportaciones de
este país otro gran amigo de uruguay es
holanda el puerto de rotterdam es el
punto de entrada a europa y buena parte
de las exportaciones uruguayas se
dirigen hacia allá
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea a diferencia
de chile que es el país más rico de la
región uruguay tiene una economía
muchísimo más diversificada el chile la
mitad de sus exportaciones dependen del
cobre el uruguay sin embargo hay
muchísimos sectores interesantes hemos
hablado ya de los refrescos el papel el
software y por supuesto la carne y la
agricultura sin embargo espera un
momento porque las cosas podrían
torcerse mucho antes de lo que pensamos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
un gobierno frente a su propio partido
desde el año 2005 la izquierda gobierna
en uruguay con un partido que se llama
el frente amplio y lo cierto es que el
partido hace honor a su nombre se trata
de un partido tan amplio que hay toda
clase de sensibilidades políticas y
creedme no ganan para discusiones el
primer presidente frenteamplista que
tuvo uruguay fue tabaré vázquez después
como los mandatos en este país no pueden
prorrogarse le sucedió josé mujica esa
rockstar de la izquierda luego volvimos
a tener otra vez a tabaré vázquez tres
cambios de presidente pero sin embargo
hay algo que no cambia el ministro de
economía danilo astori quedaos con su
nombre porque es muy importante
[Música]
sin embargo pese a todo este consenso
del que hablábamos antes el frente
amplio es de todo menos tranquilo dentro
del propio partido hay un ala radical y
otra la más moderada que sería la que
representan vázquez y astori mujica de
alguna forma estaría entre medias y eso
explica que cada vez que el gobierno ha
propuesto un tratado de libre comercio
con otro país se ha encontrado con la
oposición frontal del ala más radical
del partido pasado en el primer gobierno
de vázquez cuando intentó firmar un
acuerdo con eeuu ha pasado hace poco
tiempo cuando el nuevo gobierno de
vázquez ha querido firmar un tratado con
chile y podría ocurrir de nuevo pero
esta vez con china en el año 2018
cumpliremos 30 años de relaciones
diplomáticas y hemos fijado esa fecha
como límite para firmar el tratado de
libre comercio el objetivo del gobierno
es evitar a las empresas uruguayas
aranceles anuales en china que cuestan
más de 100 millones de dólares sin
embargo dentro del frente amplio parecen
tener alergia
palabra libre comercio y por si esto
fuera poco muchos compañeros de partido
critican a danilo astori porque dicen
que gasta poco
pero precisamente ese es uno de los
grandes problemas de uruguay el gasto
público fijaos después de venezuela
uruguay es el país con mayor porcentaje
de funcionarios uno de cada cinco
empleados trabaja directamente para el
estado si a eso le sumamos el peso
brutal de la economía sumergida
tenemos que sólo la tercera parte de
todos los uruguayos en edad de trabajar
lo hacen en el mercado privado uno de
cada tres en la mayor parte de los
países desarrollados esta cifra es de
más de la mitad por supuesto que
comparado con argentina o brasil uruguay
es un auténtico paraíso en la tierra
[Música]
pero lo cierto es que si quiere seguir
creciendo tendrá que atajar estos
problemas lo antes posible
así que la pregunta es queréis que
uruguay tendría que aprobar esos
acuerdos de libre comercio y si
tuvierais que vivir en américa latina y
pudierais elegir cualquier país os
decantarías por uruguay podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios
y por supuesto no olvidéis visitar
nuestra página de patriot donde no sólo
podréis contribuir y formar parte activa
de visual política sino que además
tendréis acceso a contenido exclusivo y
si es la primera vez que entráis en este
canal no olvidéis suscribiros para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]
[Aplausos]